welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast we are back from our summer
break
and better than ever as always we've got
some really impressive feats of strength
we've got some great research reviews
covering several studies over the last
couple months
we've got some very helpful barbecue
tips now that football season is in full
swing
and we've got some huge announcements we
have a new facebook group and a new
subreddit
and those are going to allow you to join
in on the stronger by science
conversation so without further ado
let's jump into the first episode of
season
three welcome back to the stronger by
science podcast
this is your host eric trexler we are
back from summer break and we are better
than ever
for this first episode back from summer
break i've got a very special temporary
guest co-host
his name's greg knuckles greg how was
your summer break
it was fine i guess uh i don't really
have any superlatives for it mostly just
cooped up in the house lifting a lot
cooking a lot uh but yeah it was fine
how was yours it was good um
did a bunch of riding which was
enjoyable so some of that stuff will be
coming out in the future
which is very good but hey i'm excited
to be back i kind of missed recording to
be honest
yeah yeah it's uh it's gonna be fun uh
the boys are back baby the boys are back
in town but
not exactly the same we got some big
changes that that occurred over the
summer break so a couple things to keep
people
uh up to date on first of all one of the
biggest things is now there are
official designated spots on the
internet
where you can discuss the show but
really all things
stronger by science we wanted to kind of
designate some online spaces for people
to talk about the show but also just
talk about
articles that come out questions people
have for us
so we created a public facebook group
that people can join it is called the
stronger by science community so you can
easily find that on facebook
we also created a subreddit so if you go
to
reddit.com r stronger by science
that is now the stronger by science
subreddit so
greg and i get a lot of messages from
people which we're always happy to
receive
always happy to respond to but we
figured it would make sense to have
an open public place where we could
answer those questions talk about the
show and talk about
basically everything going on in the
stronger by science cinematic
universe so greg you're you're going to
be in charge of the subreddit because i
don't understand how to use reddit but
i'm going to learn that is my commitment
it's on the air
and now it's set in stone another big
change
is we have to add a new segment we
haven't come up with a title yet we only
had a summer to think of it but
we could go with the classic the classic
being obscene profit timeout
that that might be one uh we could call
it the selling out segment
or the cashing in segment we'll workshop
it post in the community
let us know what you think but the big
news is we now have a sponsor
we do for the first time ever yeah so
i am not entirely sure why they
reached out to me specifically probably
just because
i do use their products but bulk
supplements.com
reached out and said like hey uh would
you have
any interest in being a brand ambassador
and i
said pretty much like no i don't like
the
the whole vibe of brand ambassador that
just seems weird to me
but uh i am occasionally a temporary
guest co-host on a podcast would you be
interested in sponsoring the podcast
uh and they said sure and so we've uh
we've been thinking about maybe getting
a sponsor or like trying to get a
sponsor for the podcast for a bit
because it is not monetized in any way
um but we weren't really sure how to go
about that specifically just because
like
we didn't want to feel like we were
selling out super hard and like
so for example bulksupplements.com just
sells
you know individual ingredients that you
could buy yourself and mix together
we're comfortable with that but like a
few supplement companies
asked if they could sponsor the podcast
and we said no just because
we didn't want to feel like we were
beholden to them in any way shape or
form
um yeah you know like they put a dumb
combination of ingredients in a product
and now you feel like oh should we say
that that's a dumb combination of
ingredients
you know what i mean yeah yeah um so
yeah
i've been using bulk supplements as
the way that i acquire bulk supplements
for a long time
i can't remember the last time i
actually bought a branded supplement
product
uh except for athlete vitamin from
citadel nutrition
it's good um but yeah for the most part
like if i want creatine if i want
citrulline malate uh i don't buy
caffeine powder because i learned how
dangerous that was i used to
wouldn't recommend it um but yeah
uh let's see when i was playing around
with beta alanine like
i get all of my stuff from bulk book
supplements just because
uh they have good prices and you know
you know
if i'm buying from some other company i
don't know if it's
if they're like under dosing supplements
there's always a huge huge markup so
i mean bulk supplements has high quality
stuff at good prices so like i've been
using them for a long time
and so i didn't feel as ethically
compromised
to that sponsorship as as i probably
would for many other
yeah so if you go to bulksupplements.com
and during the checkout you enter the
code sbs pod
sbs pod you will get all caps all caps
you will get five percent off your order
and so think of it this way greg if you
let's say you spend in a given year
two and a half million on supplements
well i'm not saying that i'm not saying
that's like the median amount that most
people spend i'm just saying
for instance yeah i mean this is a
classic like mean versus median
like exactly you know what measure of
central tendency to use we assume that
for our listeners the median is closer
to
about a million a million five uh but
yeah mean
probably around two and a half so if
you're spending two and a half million
per year
you're using this this code you're gonna
save 125 grand
per year and depending on your real
estate market that's buying a house
just from like two to four years of
supplement savings i mean that's huge
so five percent off your order sbs pod
um and if you're a different company and
you'd like to
rent our loyalty and credibility for a
shockingly low price
hit us up maybe you'll get added to this
segment sounds good
okay let's move on um we've got a good
news segment so greg why don't you kick
us off there
yeah so um i
i struggled to find a good a good news
thing but
i did find one uh so that
defeats the whole purpose of the the
segment there are
good things that are happening they're
just difficult to find
okay i looked for a [ __ ] diamond in
the rough what what more do you expect
from me
anyway uh so i went to something that's
very near and dear to my heart
two things actually which are bears and
bulking
so this the bears of the world are about
to go into hibernation
um and so it seems like the fine bears
at katmai
national park have completed their
summer and autumn
bulking seasons successfully and so in
order to give them
kind of the praise and recognition they
deserve for their successful bulks
explore.org has a
competition it's a fat bear competition
uh
where you can vote on which bears most
successfully bulked
over this uh over the summer and autumn
uh
by the time this podcast comes out fat
bear week will have
concluded two days prior so you'll
probably be listening to this on
thursday fat bear week
uh finished up on tuesday
but if you just go to explore.org
meet hyphen the hyphen bears you can you
can check out all of the bears and
how fat they got uh and yeah i feel good
for those bears
fun fact uh let's talk about hibernation
for like five minutes
because i think people don't understand
hibernation i know i certainly didn't
i remember like learning about it in
elementary or middle school biology
class like hey here's this thing bears
do
they uh get in their den and it's nice
and cozy and they pretty much just
snooze and just generally vibe for a few
months
that's not the case at all dude
hibernation sounds like it [ __ ] sucks
i was listening to an npr segment with
someone from the duke lemur center
because apparently fat tailed lemurs
hibernate as well
and they store their fat to hibernate in
their tail
and like dude animals are not vibing at
all
when they're hibernating essentially the
process of hibernation
is you take endothermic animals that you
know
regulate their body temperature via
metabolic activity
slow the metabolic activity way way down
so they don't starve over winter
but then it's basically just a tug of
war
between starving to death and freezing
to death
and so they actually sleep for virtually
none of the time uh they're awake pretty
much
straight for for several months with
just
small little naps interspersed uh and
they're walking a tightrope
between doing a little activity to get
some
some metabolic activity so they don't
freeze to death
and trying to move as little as possible
so they don't starve to death
and basically it just sounds like the
most miserable process
and also think about bears
so uh other animals that hibernate like
lemurs
generally find dens to get into so
they'll be safe and not get attacked
during their hibernating
but apparently a lot of bears don't even
find dens so like a fair amount of them
do but since
in most environments they are the apex
predator
it's not uncommon for bears to just kind
of decide like hey
my my autumn bulk is done it's
hibernating time and just [ __ ]
lay down in the middle of a field
because they know no one's gonna mess
with them
and they just hibernate there for like
four months which that is
that is pretty cool yeah so so overall
you
for listeners who are looking for
practical takeaways you'd say just like
don't hibernate
that would be my recommendation very
cool
so in my uh installment of the good news
segment here we're sticking with the
animals theme
humans just aren't generating a lot of
good news you hate to say it but
humanity
is uh it's on the back burner for now
we're focusing on the animals
yeah man if i could just say like one
more
kind of depressing thing to bring down
the mood during the good news segment
so i i think making the good news
segment does actively harm my mental
health
because like dude we go on these we go
on these websites there are like
good news curated websites for i guess
people who want
uplifting things to to see about and
like
you know pick themselves up in dark
times but like
most of the good news like pieces of
content on those sites
are just severely dystopian yeah it's
like
hey there's some kid who uh
has some sort of you know major
medical issue who's gonna [ __ ] die
because their parents don't have
insurance
and like you know it's either let the
kid [ __ ] die or go in like six
figures of debt but
oh man their classmates pulled together
and ran a bake sale to like
allow them to get this treatment they
needed it's like on one hand
you know good for the classmates that is
nice it shows humanity pulling together
but like the whole [ __ ] premise of
the story wouldn't exist if uh
a lot of [ __ ] hadn't gone and gone wrong
on the front end like
yeah both the fact that the kid has some
sort of like major medical issue and two
the fact that our medical system
basically puts people in a gambit of
like let kids [ __ ] die
or put families in debt for generations
like i feel like on the whole that's not
good news
it's it's so unfortunately i'm playing
right into your hand here oh no
um oh no so my good news starts with
some bad news
no but this is a great example um and
believe it or not i doubt you did enough
prep for the show to read my good news
link
oh i absolutely did not so um
telequa or tahlequah i think
uh was it was a whale is a whale who had
a
in in 2018 uh she was all over the news
she had a little baby whale it passed
away it was very sad
people all over the world were watching
um
but she has a new baby a new healthy
baby so uh
it was a very sad story everybody was
kind of grieving with this poor whale
mom who lost her baby
but she had a new baby mother and baby
are doing well so it's a nice little
feel-good story but
one of the reasons i had to to use this
is it's kind of a personal
uh story for me so um greg if you were
to think of a word to describe me what
would it be
sophisticated sure yeah yeah um so
sophisticated gentleman that i am a
couple years ago
i took a nice young woman on a date a
cool date we went to an
art exhibit and it was uh collaborations
between an artist and a scientist
um doing art exhibits based on the
science they do
so like a lot of cool imaging work that
had been kind of
you know biomedical imaging would be
given to an artist to kind of put their
creative spin on it
there's a lot of ocean stuff a lot of
really cool ocean stuff and i was like
oh you know what we should do we should
watch an episode of that uh i think it's
called
blue earth yeah yeah and i had never
seen it but i was like look at these
cool beautiful ocean things that would
be a cool
thing to do so it was the second date
with this person and um there was a very
emotional whale scene
in blue earth that i didn't know was
there and so um
you know second date with somebody
you're thinking okay still got to make a
good impression
hopefully there will be a third date
right what you don't want to do is look
over during date number two and see
tears she was crying because of this
really sad whale scene that was very
similar to uh
talaqua's uh initial 2018 ordeal
uh so i was like this is not going well
um
i was not certain if there would be a
third date because tears are not a good
thing
but there was a third date and many more
it's actually
uh my current girlfriend so it's that
was a couple years ago still going
strong but
i owe her a positive story about a whale
and a baby
and this is the positive whale and baby
story
nice so now we're even it's all good
yeah that's good to hear okay
that's that's not nearly as dark and
dystopian as the stuff i was talking
about
no i'm always good with like he's a sad
i'm good with like a happy animal story
or like an animal redemption story
like whatever yeah okay so let's let's
move on to humans for
a small amount of time here let's do it
the rest of the show
what about feats of strength we've been
gone for a while certainly people have
continued to
lift weights yeah they have uh
in the outline you specifically told me
to limit myself to one to three total
uh so this is a relatively short feats
of strength segment
uh and pretty recent stuff so
joe sullivan uh recently set the
all-time squat world record
in the uh hundred kilo class or 220
pound class
uh without wraps so he squatted
kilos or 822 pounds
that beats ahmet's appears uh previous
record by half a kilo or about a pound
uh i think we've talked about
some of amit's previous records and
questionable depth
in relation to kevin oak breaking some
of his other records
um the previous 220 record was not
as much of uh an utter [ __ ] shows like
the 242 record that ahmed held was
uh but it was also questionable joe's
depth on the other hand was
flawless he buried it really really
really great lift
uh so kudos to joe the other one
is uh tumas haltala
i think he's oh man i should have noted
this i think he's swedish
he competes in ipf in the ipf affiliates
as far as i'm aware that's what his most
recent comms have been in
uh and he pulled 400 kilos or 881 pounds
at a body weight of
106 kilos or 234 pounds
uh which is crazy impressive he seems
like he's made a lot of progress
his best previous pull in a meet is 370
kilos or 815 pounds
so that's substantial progress for
someone who's already that strong
and if he were to pull 400 kilos
in the ipf that would tie for the
third biggest drug tested pull of all
time
and the only two people who have pulled
more
in a tested competition are mark henry
and
mikhail kuklav which i'll note
i didn't know that caclieve ever
competed drug tested
that one surprised me a little bit i'm
not going to elaborate on that further
but anyway um like
i mean a 400 kilo deadlift is [ __ ]
strong
regardless of how someone competes or
how much they weigh but
the fact that he competes tested and he
only weighs 106 kilos
crazy crazy impressive deadlift good
stuff
all right so during our break a lot of
research happened it just kept pushing
forward the science never stops
it did and so for that reason we want to
do a research roundup segment
got quite a few studies to talk about
here so each one going to keep it pretty
brief just do a little snapshot
just to keep the people updated about
what kind of science is happening so
i'm gonna kick things off here um
i was looking through uh you know we do
the the journal sweep
every month for mass kind of choosing
what uh what articles
we're gonna write each month and so when
i was looking through the list of
articles that came out
i saw one about cannabis consumption and
uh it kind of i was pretty interested in
it because i was hoping that
maybe there would be some glimpses of
like some cbd type interventions
um you know because cbd oil is
everywhere and there's just really not
much research on it
i was hoping maybe there would be
something about chronic training
adaptations in there
um but but this study specifically or
just scientific proof that marijuana
usage is
the peak of moral depravity yeah and
there really wasn't
anything in there about moral depravity
whatsoever which
i don't know who reviewed it i don't
know who the editor was but
you want to you want to tell both sides
of that if you're going to do science
that's a major oversight
yeah but but anyway it just specifically
looked at the acute effects of cannabis
consumption
on exercise performance so um
it what was really surprising is that
there's just not a lot of research on
this
i guess it shouldn't be that surprising
um it's it's pretty difficult to get
permission to do that
yeah like there's not a ton of exercise
research on crack cocaine
that's true and um the two are very
similar
to some yes um but anyway so so
they they had eight peer-reviewed
publications that
they looked at in the systematic review
uh and ten literature reviews so it's
one of those things people like
people like writing about it but it's
just it's hard to actually
do the research on it um you know it's
like bfr research
circa 2013. yeah like four studies and
19 narrative reviews yeah
yeah um so anyway yeah there's
people are interested in it but there's
just not that much primary
original research to go with um but but
they looked at those
those studies that were available and it
makes sense you know like
i i think after the 80s specifically
in the united states if you're trying to
get the irb to approve it like
it just wasn't gonna happen yeah so um
in this systematic review they looked at
studies that included two different
delivery routes uh either
inhalation of the the thc
or oral ingestion of the thc so edible
um thc interventions
so the results um basically showed that
cannabis consumption prior to
exercise was unfavorable for performance
so
subjects were had a reduced ability to
maintain their effort
and to maintain physical you know
maximal work capacity during exercise
and there were some undesirable
physiological responses
as well so um heart rate and breathing
rate were
increased uh myocardial oxygen demand
was increased
at a given intensity of exercise and
those aren't
favorable things when it comes to the
physiological responses to exercise
and then there's some neurological
effects as well that that influenced
balance um so so there was uh at least
one study looking at sway
that i recall so some of some of the
neuromuscular control was just a little
bit skewed
so based on the articles in this review
and again it's a very small body of
literature
unsurprisingly um they basically said
hey
pre-exercise cannabis consumption
probably not a great idea
i'd still be really interested to see
it's one of those questions we get a lot
where where people are like hey i enjoy
using cannabis
it's legal where i live so you know
leave me alone
but is it really going to impair my
gains over time if you know
in the evening i'm consuming it and you
know
none of the studies in this um
systematic review would really give any
um any useful information for that
question
but it definitely seems uh seems
inadvisable to use thc
directly prior to exercise so in this
study
they were looking at exercise that
occurred anywhere from 20 to about 200
minutes
after the thc was ingested so within
those couple hours before exercise it
definitely looks like
thc use is is not advisable
one thing to to keep in mind is that
this systematic review might have even
underestimated the unfavorable responses
the reason being a lot of these studies
were published between 1974
and 1986 and so um
the authors mentioned that at that time
the thc dosage
in a single joint that would be used in
this type of study
was between 5 and 25 milligrams of thc
um but times have changed greg
so a thc concentration in a joint today
might be as high as like 150 milligrams
per joint
uh and so just another reason that
society is going to hell in a hand
basket
unbelievable exactly so so it's quite
possible you know this systematic review
found some unfavorable
physiological effects acutely after thc
consumption some unfavorable effects on
performance it's possible that the
effects are even more unfavorable
given the fact that the thc dosage per
unit of cannabis
has has really kind of skyrocketed since
these studies occurred
um and again this is purely looking at
consuming it directly before exercise or
within an hour or two beforehand so
this is not this really has no bearing
on whether or not
uh thc or cannabis can be utilized it's
just
can it be utilized effectively before a
workout and the answer seems to be
probably not yeah i mean i think uh
i think what you touched on with this
body of literature being
incomplete due to the dosages being used
i think that's a good point
um another thing that i think is
very unfortunate that it hasn't been
looked into yet is
is like you said they've looked at
things like uh changes in
heart rate and breathing rate and
myocardial oxygen demand
i think it's it's pretty unfortunate
that they haven't looked at the effects
of thc on strength because
i mean if i know anything about the
effects of marijuana from the
documentary film reefer madness
uh it can just make people fly into a
rage
and uh exhibit super physiological
strength levels yeah so i think that uh
i think that research is definitely
needed on that
i just find it disappointing every time
that you talk trash on marijuana we get
like 96 negative ratings on itunes so
we finally make the lim the leap we've
got a sponsor now
it's quite an industrious enterprise
we've got going here and you drive it
into the ground
i mean once once bulk supplements start
selling thc powder i might change my
all right to be clear to our listeners
it's a bit it's yeah it's just a bit
it's just a bit all right so a recent
study came out
by norm and colleagues uh titled
caffeine increases strength and power
performance in resistance
trained females during early follicular
phase
and this is the results are basically
what one would expect
so we've talked about caffeine on the
podcast quite a bit before
there's i don't know probably like eight
or ten different meta-analyses
showing basically that uh caffeine
improves virtually all aspects of
anaerobic performance so
one rep max strength strength endurance
isometric strength isokinetic strength
power output
uh like so it tends to have like
pretty modest effects on all of those
things but they seem to be
you know consistently and meaningfully
positive
one of the drawbacks is that virtually
all of the research
looking at the effect of caffeine on
anaerobic performance and strength
performance specifically
has used exclusively male subjects so
you know we've talked about before how
uh
the the resistance training literature
does tend to be
pretty male biased in terms of of
subject pools
but caffeine is caffeine research is
uh substantially more slanted towards
male subjects than
than the literature as a whole um and so
it was good to see this study
in in female lifters so uh they
they did a crossover study
placebo-controlled uh
subjects took either a placebo or four
milligrams per kilogram of caffeine
before exercise
and then you know 50 50 to start with
and then after a washout period
the people who took the placebo first
took caffeine and vice versa
and they were looking at the effect on
counter movement jump height
squat 1rm squat reps to failure with 60
of 1rm uh bench one rep max bench reps
to failure
uh and several other things but those
were the outcomes that i was the most
interested in
uh and all of those things increased all
of the increases were
again as one would expect looking at the
previous literature
uh pretty modest so trivial to small
effect sizes but
uh significant effects in favor of
caffeine consumption
um one thing to note is that
a lot of the studies in this area have
used subjects
who weren't habitual caffeine consumers
uh
or or who were low habitual caffeine
consumers
the subjects in this study actually on
average
used a bunch of caffeine um you know
just in day-to-day life
so one of the things the authors did was
to look to see if habitual caffeine
consumption
was associated with the ergogenicity of
caffeine
for their various outcome measures and
they found that with the exception of
reps to failure
uh habitual caffeine consumption didn't
seem to
affect how much caffeine usage
outperformed
placebo so basically um
you know it could be that people who are
habitual caffeine users
may not get as much of a ergogenic
strength endurance effect
from using caffeine before workouts but
otherwise like regardless of whether you
don't use caffeine or you
do habitually use quite a bit of
caffeine caffeine does still seem to be
ergogenic for
for most outcomes um
another thing to note about this study
since it did use female athletes
is uh they specifically collected data
during the early follicular phase of the
menstrual cycle
that's important because uh one of the
things about caffeine
is um there are reasons to
suspect that the effects of caffeine on
exercise performance
might be different between the sexes
mostly because
estrogen affects caffeine metabolism
and the early follicular phase is um you
know
during menses or maybe up to a couple
days post menses if uh
if a woman has like relatively short
menses
and during the early follicular phase
both estrogen and progesterone levels
are quite low
um so it could be that there might still
be sex differences in exercise
performance
uh or like the the effects of caffeine
on exercise performance if it was
measured at some other point in the
menstrual cycle when estrogen and or
progesterone levels are higher so that's
something to note
and you know something to hopefully look
for follow-up research on
and another thing to note about this
study just kind of a
a statistical point um
is some of the results of this study are
are good examples of p-values being
influenced by both
magnitude and consistency so
someone might pull up the full text of
the study and look and see that
there was a significant increase in
bench press performance when people use
caffeine instead of a placebo
pre-workout but the actual like mean
the mean values for both conditions were
66 kilos
for placebo and 68 kilos for caffeine
and someone might look at that and say
that's only a two kilo increase
how could that be significant especially
you know since this study didn't have
like 500 subjects or something
and that's because p-values are
determined both by magnitude and
consistency of effects
and so uh this this study shows the
individual results
and i think one subject had
no difference between the caffeine and
placebo conditions and every other
subject
uh benched somewhere between one and
four kilos more
when they use caffeine than when they
use the placebo
so it was a very very consistent effect
it was a small effect but it was very
consistent
um and so like that's that's still
worthwhile
and that tells you you know if uh
if something has like a large mean
effect but it's super variable
it might be great for some people and
actually bad for other people
but in the case of caffeine it seems to
have relatively consistent effects
if you take so much that it makes you
like freak out and get super jittery it
might be ergolytic but otherwise
it's probably going to either have no
effect or a small positive effect
and so yeah like knowing both the
magnitude and consistency of an effect i
think is
is pretty important and both of those
things go into a p-value
yeah it is crazy with the caffeine
literature there was a paper by del coso
a couple years ago that was highlighting
the discrepancy
of male versus female um participant
representation
within the caffeine literature and i
can't remember
the proportion off the top of my head
but i'm pretty sure it was like 80 20.
like like it was it was pretty lopsided
so
whenever you see another paper come out
uh particularly when it comes to
anaerobic outcomes it's always good to
see more research being done on caffeine
specifically
in female subjects okay moving on
uh i found a really cool paper uh the
title was
appetitive traits as targets for weight
loss
the role of food cue responsiveness and
satiety responsiveness
and the whole idea here was was looking
at these different appetite related
traits of people and seeing
how they they tend to correlate with um
with binge eating disorder but also with
overweight and obesity status
and it was kind of a review paper that
talked through some of those
associations talked through an
underlying
kind of conceptual theory about how to
actually act upon it
and they talked through some recent
research that this group has done
in terms of trying to intervene and
actually influence some of these
appetite related traits
so the whole idea that they present
is based on shakhtar's externality
theory
and the whole idea is that overeating
and binge eating are related to high
levels
of reactivity to external cues to eat
and also
reductions in sensitivity to our
internal
satiety signal so the idea is that
people who are
more prone to overeating whether it's
binge eating episodes or just kind of
typical overeating in general leading to
overweight and obesity
the idea is that there are some of these
appetite related traits
inherent to these individuals which are
developed you know that they're not you
know
intrinsic and unchangeable but but but
there are these appetite-related traits
that seem to correlate with these
overeating behaviors where people tend
to be
a little bit more responsive to external
cues that cause them to
eat and eventually overeat and there's
there's a little bit lower sensitivity
to typical
intrinsic satiety signals right
and so the idea is these cues by the way
it can be really just about anything
these external cues it could be
you know every time i walk by a subway
and i smell the the bread baking i'm
like man
i could definitely go for some bread
right like that could be a cue
ooh did you see i did see was it ireland
yeah a court in ireland ruled that the
bread used for subway subs
is not in fact bread yeah i think it's
legally considered a cake
or something like that in ireland it's
it's a non-bred product
for sure i think we now have to admit
that food babe was right all along
let us be the first to do so vani if you
want to sponsor the podcast
uh our email is open to you
yeah so um but anyway there's those
external cues right like you're
presented with this food that you really
like and that can be a cue
but it can also be the environment that
you're in or just habits you've
developed right so like for me
personally
uh if it's late night and i'm sitting
down to like watch something on tv
i i typically want to like go make some
popcorn like i just really like
snacking on popcorn so i've associated
the food with the activity
and it might cause me to eat at a time
where i have high satiety like i'm not
actually physiologically hungry
and so the idea is that these traits
where we we've got these different cues
that can cause us to overeat
and a blunted sensitivity to satiety
cues that actually tell us like
you're good you're totally full it's
time to stop eating
the balance of those different um
factors
could have a big a big role in
somebody's propensity to overeat
and so they've done some really cool um
really cool interventions with this
group
so it's kind of one big comprehensive
intervention with multiple
um components to it but they do stuff
like uh
they encourage their participants to um
monitor their hunger before during and
after a meal like
actually take time to think through it
and monitor that
and use a one to five scale before the
meal um you know
how is your hunger level or satiety
level actually give it a rating
and then doing it doing it again during
the meal and then again after the meal
and just kind of reinforcing the idea of
getting in tune specifically with
satiety cues
without being influenced by other things
that cause us to eat such as
you know one of the obvious ones is just
the hedonic sensation of like i'm eating
this because it's really good
and like it stimulates the reward
centers of my brain like
so so getting in touch with those
satiety cues by actually practicing it
they also do a thing when it when it
comes to food cues
where they would bring in their high
craving foods to an actual
in-lab visit when they were already like
totally satiated right so they're full
they're not hungry they don't have a
high desire to eat
and they would bring in their like their
biggest trigger foods that cause them to
overeat that they tend to crave
and it was it was honestly just like
typical like exposure therapy right just
kind of like
hanging out with this food but being in
a state where you're like no i'm
i'm just not gonna eat it because i'm
not hungry and i don't need to you know
so doing a little bit of that exposure
they also had them do a one to five
craving scale
at home so they were doing the hunger
scales at periodic times
but also the craving scales and starting
to actually think through
am i hungry am i having cravings what
might be causing me to have a desire to
eat
at this particular time and then of
course they gave them education
about the about how neurobiological
physiological
psychological and environmental factors
all
can kind of trigger overeating in
particularly vulnerable individuals so
it's not just going in and trying to
intervene on some of these things but
actually developing an
understanding of what are all these
different things that can contribute
to the desire to eat or the desire to
overeat
and so then they would also give them
some coping skills as part of the
intervention so
they would basically say when you've got
an urge to eat and you're not
physiologically hungry
what can we actually do about that so
one thing is just
changing the physical state of the body
so they would do like deep breathing
exercises or relaxation exercises
they introduced some behavioral
alternatives to eating
so just kind of replacing it with other
behaviors
rather than eating at that time changing
their attentional focus so
some kind of distraction or imagery
self-motivational statements a variety
of
different things to shift their focus
and their attention
from eating or the desire to eat to
something else
and then also they worked on enhancing
motivation to resist cues
so actually kind of thinking through
cost-benefit analyses and things like
that
so one of the reasons i wanted to bring
this paper up is because i think it's
people in the evidence-based fitness
world when it comes to nutrition
it's usually you know we we treat people
like they're robots right it's like oh
you've got a nutrition problem
change the calorie number change the
macro composition
maybe change your food selection but
getting into some of these behavioral
components i think a lot of people
overlook that
and underestimate how big of a barrier
some of these things can be you know
when someone is really really responsive
to external cues to eat
or someone has uh has really
lost that that ability to tap into their
internal satiety cues
that can be such a huge factor and such
a huge barrier when it comes to weight
loss
and so like for me i've always found
weight loss to be
weirdly easy and i've always wondered
why that is because
i'd like to believe i'm just really
awesome but i just don't think that's
the case
right so one of the things that's
interesting and this is really huge for
coaches like
if you're a coach and you've been really
good at something and you see people
struggle with it
you got to think through like what might
actually be causing these divergent
responses to a given intervention right
so like
if you were born strong and you're just
genetically strong and you've always
been strong and everything you do works
and build strength
you have to really think hard about your
clients that are struggling to put on
strength
and think what's the difference here and
what are some strategies and solutions
so
i i think it's really interesting like
when i read this paper i was like yeah i
mean
i have really low responsiveness to
external food cues and that was
something that
i mean maybe it's inherent or innate
maybe it was developed when i was
younger but it's never been a problem
for me but
thinking through it you can see how for
a lot of people that's a huge barrier to
weight loss success
same thing uh i did have an experience
where i completely lost touch with my
satiety cues
one of the first bodybuilding preps i
did after the competition
i was purely eating for hedonic
sensations
like my nutrition had nothing to do with
obtaining nutrients at that point
and it was crazy because when you're in
that like really
when you've got that serious
post-competition hyperphagia
you're like eating past satiety to a i
mean
to an extent you just couldn't even
believe like i've never been that
full and thought i'm going in for more
like
you know somebody hold me back so it's
just really interesting to think through
some of these things and think
about nutrition outside of the macros
outside of these little food swaps
and get into the behaviors get into the
things that can predispose someone to
overeat
and if you're a coach knowing about this
stuff is really critical
and the thing i really like about it is
that there are some actionable things
you can do
to actually uh influence some of these
things so it you know if you've got a
client or if you yourself
are really responsive to external eating
cues
there are things you can do to actually
be proactive
and try to address that head on which i
think is really cool so
it was really nice paper and and for
someone who like i would never claim to
have any expertise
on the behavioral side of things when it
comes to nutrition but even for someone
like me
you could you could dive into the paper
and really get some good stuff out of it
yeah so so my next is uh effects of
horizontal and inclined bench press on
neuromuscular adaptations and untrained
young men
by chavez and colleagues um
and so i wanted to talk about this paper
for a couple reasons
one is that so there have been like a
fair amount of
emg studies on various pressing
variations so you know flat bench close
grip inch wide grip
incline decline etc whatever
uh and then people trying to draw
inferences about hypertrophy from
emg differences which is uh
you know somewhat suspect uh it's not
quite like reading tarot cards but it's
not
it's a very tenuous yeah to make yeah
uh and so this was the first study
uh comparing longitudinal adaptations uh
between flat bench and incline bench and
so
um you know i think like most people
would read this and be like okay
hypertrophy is really the only outcome
that matters here
uh you know do you need incline to build
your upper chest
uh and is it that much better and
will it maybe neglect your lower chest
like do you need to do both
uh but they they looked at both
hypertrophy and strength so the
hypertrophy measures they took were
peck thicknesses at three different
points so
uh in the second third and fifth
intercostal spaces
um which you can just think of as like
upper mid and lower chest and uh also
they looked at strength
uh they they did isometric uh
flat bench and incline bench as their
strength assessments
which you know i wasn't crazy about but
it is what it is
um and so they had people trained for
for eight weeks
uh just pressing once a week and they
had three groups one of them was doing
only flat bench
one of them was doing only incline press
and
the other one was doing 50 50 flat and
inclined bench
for four to six total sets of pressing
per week sets of eight to twelve to
failure so you know pretty basic
straightforward hypertrophy training
and in terms of what they found is that
all three groups had
similar strength outcomes uh assessed
via
changes in isometric incline and flat
bench
i didn't find that too surprising
someone could look at that and be like
oh
so exercise specificity is a lie it
didn't
pan out in this study i don't
necessarily think that's the case
because they weren't doing isometric
bench press for their training
so i think that an isometric test is
more just testing kind of like
generalized pressing strength instead of
the actual motor patterns that were
being changed
but anyway all all three interventions
had
similar impacts on on isometric pressing
strength
in terms of growth which is what people
probably mostly care about
is that middle and lower pet growth were
similar in all three groups
but there was more upper pet growth in
the group
doing exclusively inclined bench so
uh you could read that and i think quite
a few people
have read that because i've seen quite a
few people
uh sharing and discussing this study you
could look at that and say like hey look
the bodybuilders were right all along if
you want to develop your upper chest you
need to do some incline pressing
maybe that's with a barbell maybe it's
with dumbbells but
you know you really really need the
incline work to build your upper chest
and i think that's probably true um
but there was a really weird thing about
this study that i haven't seen anyone
discussing
and that's that just like the
hypertrophy outcomes were [ __ ]
bonkers
so uh there were
nine different hypertrophy outcomes so
upper middle and lower pet growth in
three different groups
uh and these the the smallest amount of
hypertrophy in any group for any region
for any region of the pecs was a 24
increase in thickness
the largest was a 62 percent increase in
thickness
which was basically going from like 15
millimeters to 25 millimeters give or
take
which is crazy and the average across
all groups and all sites was 44
so averaging across all groups and all
sites
that's a rate of increase in peck
thickness of about five percent
per week and for for that one that was a
62
increase that's like six and a quarter
percent per week
uh and so you might hear that and say
like oh well
it might just be acute edema like did
they take the ultrasound scans
you know 20 minutes after the last
training session or like a day after the
last training session
no it says in the methods they took
those ultrasound scans
a week after the final training session
which should be
plenty of time for edema to dissipate um
and just to contextualize like how
extreme
a five or like six and a quarter percent
increase per week
is for uh changes in pec thickness
there's a review paper from 2007 by worn
bomb
that everyone cites that just like takes
all of the
the hypertrophy literature up to 2007
and just looks at like you know how does
intensity affect hypertrophy how does
volume in reps per week affect
hypertrophy how does
total length of training time affect
rates of hypertrophy
and there was like one study in
in the that was cited in the worm bomb
review that found
a rate of hypertrophy of like five
percent per week
but that was in a study that i think
lasted either one week or two weeks
so you know that's not hypertrophy that
is edema
um and the next highest was i think like
three percent per week so we're seeing
rates of hypertrophy
up to twofold faster than have
ever been reported previously uh
so anyway you could read this paper and
say hey
you got to do incline pressing to build
your upper chest or you could read this
paper and say
hey how the [ __ ] did people grow that
much period
uh and the choice dear listener is up to
you
i really like season three greg is is a
changed man
you've already said you know what the
food babe was right and now you're
saying you know what the bodybuilders
were right and this is a very humble
version of greg in season three
i really like this oh man all right
let's talk creatine everybody likes
creatine
so new paper out creatine
supplementation does not influence the
ratio between
intracellular water and skeletal muscle
mass in resistance trained men
so the whole idea this is something i've
been really thinking about lately
um why i don't know it just keeps me up
at night but
for the longest time when it comes to
creatine the biggest question that
bodybuilders always ask
is do i need to cut it before a
competition
or you know fitness models do i need to
cut it before a photo shoot
the idea being you know creatine
could potentially cause some fluid
retention and they don't want to look
watery and puffy and bloated and lose
definition due to water retention
and so i think probably the most common
answer to that
is don't worry about it creatine is
stored within
the cell and it draws water into the
cell because it's
osmolytic and so if anything you know
the cell is gonna you know
puff up and it's gonna draw water from
the extracellular space and you're going
to look huge
and shredded and good to go but
for some reason i was like what's the
the evidence for that
and several weeks ago i started looking
into it and
while that sounds good theoretically
that just doesn't seem to be what
happens in studies that look at
intracellular and extracellular water
in response to creatine so this study um
i did deduct two study points out of a
hundred
i have a running tally the way they
calculated effect size got under my skin
a little bit but
anyone who reads mass knows that greg
and i just complain about that all the
time so i'm not gonna dwell on it but
anyway
that that's really not critical to
understanding the study
what they found was uh they it was a
nice study they did this really long
lead-in kind of training program i think
was like 16 weeks of training
leading into it to get everybody kind of
on the same footing
and then an actual eight-week training
intervention with the creatine being
provided
and what they found you know one group
got creatine one group got placebo they
all did eight weeks of resistance
training
intracellular water increased more in
the creatine group than the placebo
group
and that was a statistically significant
difference
but the extracellular water changes did
not differ
between groups and so you might look at
that on the surface and say oh
intracellular water there was a
difference extracellular water there was
not
and so clearly that's that's what we're
seeing right water drawn out of the
extracellular compartment into the
intracellular
and we're good to go but those results
don't
actually mean that extracellular water
didn't increase
at all in response to creatine
supplementation
and they don't necessarily even indicate
that there was a
disproportionate shift of fluid from the
extracellular
to the intracellular space and so in
this study
the the increases in skeletal muscle
mass intracellular water and total body
water
were higher in the creatine group than
the placebo but
the ratio of intracellular water to
skeletal muscle mass that ratio did not
change due to creatine supplementation
and so if you look at just basically
the simple ratio what percentage of
their total body water was
intracellular or extracellular that
particular
ratio stayed pretty constant and so
those changes in intracellular water
were largely due or largely attributable
to an increase in skeletal muscle mass
that occurred over the the duration of
the
intervention and so when you look at
other studies that have done similar
things
where we give one group creatine the
other group a placebo and
look at changes in extracellular water
intracellular water
total body water what we do find
is that creatine tends to increase total
body water a little bit
uh both in short-term and in long-term
interventions
and what we find is that the actual
ratio of
you know intracellular water to
extracellular water doesn't really
change much
it stays pretty stable so it looks like
creatine can increase total body water
but it doesn't look like there's some
huge
shift from the extracellular to the
intracellular
fluid compartment so i just think a lot
of people
are kind of saying that because it feels
good and because it seems right
but i don't think the evidence actually
supports that idea
that your cells you know your cells are
just going to be like sponges and your
muscles are sucking up this fluid from
the extracellular compartment
um and when you think about it so if we
want to say like how much does creatine
go
up so there are non-responders and there
are people that have really high
responses to creatine supplementation
but generally speaking you could say
it'll go up about 20 all right
your muscle creatine saturation after
supplementation so if
your muscle creatine saturation goes up
20
from supplementation the overall
osmolarity
of your muscle cells only gonna increase
by two or three percent
and so because to be clear there are a
lot of things in your muscles
other than creatine absolutely yeah so
so we think oh god 20 percent higher
creatine that's going to be
20 percent higher osmolarity there's
going to be this huge shift in fluid
it's really a much more subtle shift and
uh you know there is something called
regulatory volume decrease where
the cell can kind of balance things out
um you know even in response to a pretty
big osmotic stress
and so things do seem to kind of balance
out in terms of that intracellular and
extracellular
uh fluid storage so i i don't think it's
fair to say that
the water weight that might be
attributable to creatine
is purely due to intracellular fluid
however
i still think that the the take home
uh like the the actual practical
implications are probably similar
like i i don't think that just because
there's a small increase in
extracellular water
that that means a bodybuilder should be
cutting creatine before a competition
or that a fitness model should be
cutting their creatine before a photo
shoot
because you have to keep in mind
extracellular water is
not the same thing as subcutaneous water
i think a lot of people have
that in their mind that if there's an
increase in extracellular water
for some reason it's just going to go
straight under the skin and wash out all
your definition and it's going to be
bad news that's not the case there's a
lot of different places for
extracellular water to go
and really only that subcutaneous fluid
storage is going to really make a big
difference in terms of how you look
on stage or in your photo shoot so and
everyone knows
for that all all you need to do is
switch to a tilapia
only diet because that thins the skin
exactly
well and some rice cakes tilapia or rice
cake correct yeah
so um but yeah so the idea is you can
still keep your creatine in
if you're a bodybuilder getting ready
for a photo shoot whatever the case may
be
but i think we probably ought to be a
little bit more cautious about
definitively stating if you take
creatine you're going to have this big
increase in intracellular water
and no increase at all in extracellular
water that that doesn't
seem to be supported by any of the
studies that have actually looked at
that directly
where do you think that came from do you
think it was like partially reactive
because i remember
i mean i remember maybe like a decade
ago a bunch of people saying like hey if
you take creatine you're gonna get super
bloated
do you think that there was almost you
know just kind of like a pendulum swing
where people were like no it's actually
fine to take creatine
and in fact it's good actually because
it's gonna make you
look leaner yeah i think it probably was
reactionary and i think it's one of
those
the logic is intuitive enough that you
wouldn't think too hard about it
you know like there are some claims
where you would say well i got to see
some evidence for this
but with creatine and intracellular
water storage
i think it's such an intuitive thing
that you could say oh yeah that totally
makes sense
not think too hard about fluid balance
and fluid distribution and say yeah
it's just going to go in the cell
extracellular is not going to change at
all because why would it
and i think it was just so intuitive
that it kind of
would preclude you from actually digging
in and saying well somebody's got to
show me this
and so if you look at the studies where
you actually try to really assess that
you might find one study and this is
this is another thing that i think
contributes to it
if you look at a study it's not uncommon
with these studies to see that the
increase in
intracellular water is statistically
significant
and the increase in extracellular is not
but when you actually calculate the
ratios it's pretty much unchanged
and that's just because there's more
intracellular than ex
extracellular water period right yeah
yeah there is so so intracellular um you
know
is typically going to be 60 66
of your total body water uh it is a
slightly larger
um fluid compartment than extracellular
water
so that that plays into it for sure in
terms of finding that statistical
significance you've got a little bit
more fluctuation going on
um but but yeah so in fitness we have
these things that just become cliche
right like you just repeat it over and
over and i know i've probably said that
dozens of times in the past because like
everybody says it right no it's just
intracellular don't worry about it
um and there's a little bit more nuance
to it than that but the take-home point
is still the same i don't think people
should be cutting their creatine before
bodybuilding shows or photo shoots
because you know
extracellular water probably will
increase a little bit but it's probably
not going to
unfavorably affect the physique that
checks out
all right uh my next study and i believe
my last study
for this research roundup is titled mu
opioid receptor-induced
synaptic plasticity in dopamine neurons
mediates the rewarding properties of
anabolic androgenic steroids
by bon timpi and banshee
so that was a mouthful and i'm not going
to get into
the details of this study too much
firstly because
i think i understand it pretty well but
this is comfortably outside
my like core area of expertise so if i
tried to explain it i'd probably get
uh several details wrong um and also
because like
i don't know i i feel like this is one
of the so this is
this is a mouse study and so i think
that the concept
matters more than uh
like the the specific experimental model
and findings
um but anyway so one of the
things i've seen bandied about
on the forums and argued over for a long
long time
is whether or not steroids are
addictive in kind of the classical sense
and uh some people who generally tend to
be like
pretty radically anti-steroid uh just
treat steroid addiction as if it's like
a
thing that you know basically functions
the same way as like
nicotine addiction or like you know
the worst of them marijuana addiction um
but yeah so there will be some people
saying that
and then a lot of people who uh
i suspect either use steroids or uh at
least like have buddies who use steroids
we'll say like no no they're they're not
actually addictive but like
they may kind of appear to be addictive
because people go on them
they get crazy gains and like they don't
want to lose their gains and so
like yeah of course they're going to
keep taking them but it's more because
they like the outcome
less than like you know actual like
chemical processes in the brain induced
by the steroids
uh and so this was a paper in mice
basically looking to see
if uh like neural [ __ ] that looks like
neural [ __ ] that happens when people
take classically addicted
addictive substances also occur when
you give my steroids uh and so
basically they did um so there was
uh what's it called like when you get a
runner's high
like what are those things endorphins
yeah yeah yeah so uh
when they gave these rats steroids there
was a pretty large increase in
endorphins
uh and impacts on the mu
opioid receptor that caused some
synaptic changes that looked relatively
comparable to changes that would be
induced with actual opioid injection
and so basically the authors of the
study argue that
for for some people and i guess just
mammals in general
uh steroids might actually be kind of
classically
addictive uh and the findings of this
study
do actually comport relatively well with
some observational human research so
there's some human research showing
that people who are habitual users of
steroids
when prescribed opioid pain medication
are more likely to become
addicted to or dependent on opioids than
people who are prescribed those same
medications who aren't
also habitual steroid users so it seems
like there's
there's some degree of overlap in
in the kind of addiction
causing or influencing neural pathways
uh between opioids and steroids
uh and that people who might be at an
elevated risk of
opioid addiction or dependence might
also be at a somewhat elevated risk
of steroid addiction or dependence
and so to be clear
i'm not saying not not even coming
anywhere close to saying
that everyone who uses steroids are
addicted to steroids
nor am i saying that uh addiction is
even likely so
one of the things to note is like the
the
qualitative neural impacts
seem to be similar between steroids and
opioids but the
magnitude of those impacts way way
bigger with opioids
so like don't
clip this and say like hey greg is
saying that steroids are just as
addictive as [ __ ] vicodin because i'm
not
um or even cheese or
or even cheese and certainly not
marijuana um
but i think i think this is just
something
to generally be aware of so one of the
things we've talked about
on this podcast multiple times is like
we don't give a [ __ ] if people use
steroids but
you know before you do anything like
before you make
any sort of momentous decision uh
you should be fully aware of the risks
and if like actual kind of chemical
dependency
is a risk i don't think that's a risk
that a lot of people are aware of like
it's not a risk that i was aware of
um and to be clear it's not like fully
established but
there there seems to be growing evidence
that that is a
a potential risk here um so yeah like
i would say if either you have
dealt with opioid dependency issues or
you have like a family history
of opioid dependency issues maybe be
more cautious uh before deciding to
use steroids or you know just something
to be aware of to
to put into your calculus when it comes
to making that decision
i think that's one of the least
satisfying things about
getting into reading research is that
like for a paper like this like
your conclusions were basically like
here's a thing
that i'm not fully sure what to do with
but
it is a thing that exists store that
somewhere in your brain
you know like ha developing that
patience
when you're reading research and saying
like here's one paper finding a thing
that may or may not be relevant i'll
wait six or seven years and see if i'm
still concerned about it yeah you know
like it you really have to develop that
patience especially when
it's a novel idea and you're like well
we need to wait to see if this kind of
snowballs into a line of research to see
if more findings seem to kind of
converge with this finding and show a
similar thing
i remember when i first got into like
when i first found out people were doing
research about stuff i cared about and i
was like oh
so i can actually go find it myself
thinking that i would find
like open a paper and that paper would
have my answer
you know and this is one of those lines
of research where it's just not even
close
yeah and i mean also like it's it's one
of those things where
like it wouldn't necessarily be
impossible to do research like this
in humans uh not the exact study they
did on the mice because
uh to actually look at some of the
physical
neuronal changes they basically like
administered steroids to these mice
looked to see how it changed their
behavior and then like decapitated them
and uh you know so they could actually
look at their brains
yeah so you can't do that on humans um
but
you know there are are models that
people can use to do research on
addiction
um the problem is like
much like uh much like the marijuana
research that eric discussed earlier
um it's one of those things where it's
hard like you can't really do rcts
because you got to get them by an irb
and uh you know now now weed is like
legal in some places but like
recreational steroid use
isn't legal anywhere in the us like
theoretically this could be done in
another country but
at least in the us like you can't go to
an irb and say like hey we're gonna
inject people with either like a
shitload a trend or a placebo
and see how that affects like addictive
behavior so it's one of those things
where it's almost like um
so it's not as strong i'm certainly not
claiming it's as strong as like the uh
tobacco research um but
like one of the whole things with with
tobacco research and its links to cancer
was there were there were like multiple
experimental models showing that like
you know
here's the impact of tobacco smoke on
like some cell line like in vitro
research
here's some epidemiological research uh
here's
experimental research but in animals and
you put all of that together and you
start developing
uh you start developing a very very
clear idea
that uh smoking cigarettes probably
either causes or dramatically elevates
your risk of lung cancer
but then people could say like look i
mean you haven't done rcts on humans
where like
you force one group of people to smoke
four packs a day for
30 years and like give other people i
guess placebo cigarettes i don't know
um so you know until until we have that
top quality evidence to prove it
who's really to say and i feel like
that's how you know
a lot of research on marijuana is a lot
of research
on steroids is like you know
there are multiple lines of evidence
that you can look at to
kind of develop a probabilistic idea of
what some of these effects are
um but like the the number of rcts and
humans is really
low because mostly they were done before
these substances became illegal and now
that they are
illegal at least most places like it's
hard to get
something by the irb definitely
all right so the um research roundup
segment is almost over i'm just going to
take a very quick look
at a couple extra studies here so the
first one i'm not going to go into
detail because i'm actually going to be
writing
a mass article about it this upcoming
month
but i just wanted to to give a little a
little piece
to get people uh excited about this
you know to wet the appetite a bit so
this article
the reason i want to address it because
i've gotten some questions about it
because the title is
quite controversial so the title is
metabolic adaptation is an illusion
only present when participants are in
negative energy balance
and so like you know i've written about
metabolic adaptation
that's a good click bait title yeah and
so like people see that title and
they're like ooh
eric shot's fired any thoughts
so a couple things that i just want to
briefly mention
so they said gold standard methods were
used for the measurement of rmr and body
composition
and for body composition they used bod
pod the whole study is invalid now
if you're calling bod pod a gold
standard body composition
method i'm throwing out the baby with
the bath water
the whole thing's invalidated i'm being
partially facetious but
a gold standard has to mean something
you know like it either means something
or it doesn't
no one in their right mind is calling
bod pod a gold standard method
for body composition that's insane like
it's a
mostly suitable reasonably justifiable
dude i'll be honest sometimes if you
submit a paper where your only body comp
method
uh was bod pod you're nervous that the
reviewers are going to accept it
to just say like yeah that's fine the
idea that you're calling that gold
standard is
insane uh anyway getting to the real
stuff so
they they said that metabolic adaptation
is an illusion
but if you look at their results um they
did find
that at the time points they're looking
at the individuals
they're measured resting metabolic rate
was
lower than their predicted resting
metabolic rate
and you might be thinking uh well maybe
you know maybe it wasn't statistically
significant so they're saying that's why
it didn't exist like there was no
adaptation because even though it was
lower than predicted
it wasn't significant or something like
that uh
but it was so like they identified that
resting metabolic rate was lower than
predicted
and that difference between measured and
predicted was statistically significant
so how long was the actual uh
like hypocaloric intervention like was
that
week one to week nine or was that week
one to week 13
so so the whole idea was that from week
9 to week 13 that would be the
period where they were at energy balance
okay so that they would they would do
the hypocaloric thing
see it present and then after they put
them in energy balance like okay it's
totally gone
gotcha but like it was still present and
it wasn't huge but like
it was there it was statistically
significant the idea that you would take
that finding like
if you want to say like wow this is too
small to care about and you know we
challenge that this is a major
barrier to weight loss or weight
maintenance success
yeah throw that in the title but the
idea that you're just like
total illusion a figment of your
imagination it's like but you found it
yeah so do you think this comes down
like when people say metabolic
adaptation i think there's
a question of like definitions right so
um
you know are you defining metabolic
adaptation as
hey when you go into an energy deficit
your resting metabolic rate decreases
and like that's one of the things that
might make you have to drop to a lower
calorie intake than you thought you
would to continue losing weight
or you defining metabolic adaptation as
like when you achieve a steady new
lower body weight your rmr is still
decreased like when i hear people talk
about metabolic adaptation
it seems to be more similar to that
first definition that like hey
when you go into a deficit or surplus
your metabolic rate
adapts to it and you know that might
affect how many calories you have to eat
to gain or lose weight
um when people talk about metabolic
adaptation in the literature
is this what they're talking about that
like like lingering effects on rmr once
people get back to energy balance
i mean people look at it from very
different angles
i don't think there's a universal way to
look at it in the literature
i i can tell you the way that i tend to
look at it
i tend to look at it i mean i think that
being in a deficit is part of the
equation
when it comes to active weight loss so
so i am interested in seeing
when you're actively losing weight how
much lower are we seeing things drop
but another thing to keep in mind is
that i i find
resting metabolic rate to be one of the
least interesting facets of metabolic
adaptation
you know if you look at if you look at
the literature as a whole
the changes in resting metabolic rate
aren't really that notable
and they become even less notable at
energy balance
and so i i find the the
a lot of papers take that singular focus
looking at resting metabolic rate
and i understand why methodologically it
makes sense to do that because like
the other components of resting of total
energy expenditure
are quite difficult to measure but
you know when someone says like oh that
whole concept of metabolic adaptation
throw it out because of something about
resting metabolic rate at
energy balance i just think that
the the concept of understanding and
planning for metabolic adaptation is
so much more useful than just looking at
resting metabolic rate in in an energy
balance state
you know so i i think there's still a
tremendous amount of value even if we
can't really act upon it too much
of at least understanding what to expect
when we talk about
over the course of a diet what are we
going to have to do
to our caloric intake and part of that
is this
uh adaptive process that's present in an
energy balanced state but
practically speaking we have to account
for the fact that when you're in a
deficit it's
it's augmented it's exaggerated and
that's affecting our ability to push the
diet forward to some extent
and then when you factor in a lot of the
uh the endocrine changes that accompany
it
when you factor in uh some of the side
effects associated with that the fatigue
the lethargic feelings the reproductive
side effects
i mean when we talk about the series of
adaptations that accompany a pretty
serious weight loss attempt
um yeah it goes well beyond resting
metabolic rate to be sure
so a lot of people saw that title and
were like damn eric you got
dunked on by science and like first of
all i
even with their very particular approach
to defining metabolic adaptation they
still
found it um but but i i think
the utility of metabolic adaptation and
at least understanding it goes far
beyond the scope of that definition
um okay so moving on there was a couple
things i wanted to mention so
uh this paper it was called our
questionable research practices
facilitating new discoveries in sport
and exercise medicine
the proportion of supported hypotheses
is implausibly high
shocked i tell you so shocked exercise
science
you're on notice officially um it was
really cool i like this paper
they just kind of took a little survey
of uh
of the studies in sport and exercise
medicine as they called it
uh look looked at kind of a cross
section of some of the higher tier
journals
um for whatever those tiers are worth
so in in their sample that that they
looked at they had 215 original research
studies
only 60 of them reported a hypothesis of
any kind
which is [ __ ] crazy that that's a
that's a low number
when i learned about science in
what like [ __ ] seventh grade yeah
step one
is like generate a hypothesis and
step two is like you know design an
experiment then carry it out then
collect your data see if it
supports or refutes your hypothesis and
then go back to the drawing board
like dude all the [ __ ] we do
except for like systematic reviews
whatever like you don't need a
hypothesis for that uh or if you're just
like reporting normative data right
whatever
but like most of the experimental
research in our field
should have a [ __ ] hypothesis like
well they're doing hypothesis tests
yeah yeah which is crazy like uh
anything where you're reporting a
p-value that's like
reporting compatibility with a null
hypothesis but like
if you don't have a [ __ ] alternate
hypothesis what's your goddamn null
how do you define what it is that's so
crazy that's insane
yeah you'd want it to be higher than 60
percent it is the
is my response um so of those 60
that reported at least one hypothesis
um these researchers kind of identified
the primary you know main hypothesis so
of those studies 82 um
reported that their hypothesis was
supported by their study's results
so if you reported a hypothesis in your
paper 82
of the time you were saying yep and we
found exactly what we thought
uh so of those that that were supported
so of the studies whose primary
hypothesis
was supported by their results based on
their interpretation
uh 71 reported that the pr the primary
hypothesis
was fully supported by the results and
then the rest said like
it's partial support of our hypothesis
or it was just unclear if it was full or
partial
support so the idea was not many
researchers out there are reporting
hypotheses at all and those that do
typically
have a very high success rate of finding
data that support their hypothesis
and there's a number of reasons why that
might be but the general uh purpose of
this paper was to call on
people in our field like hey report more
hypotheses
and uh sometimes you should be wrong
yeah sometimes
you found something interesting i
remember you were kind of looking into
something not quite this but similar to
this and
you had found that in a lot of the
exercise science studies there were like
a ton of hypotheses that were just
the success rate was absurdly high
because the hypotheses were just like
the safest thing yeah just completely
obvious right like
if we do it eight-week aerobic exercise
intervention and untrained people
vo2 peak will go up yeah yeah like it
was just slam
dunk yeah so there there's a lot of that
um
yeah i i don't know i i have some
thoughts it's probably not worth going
down this rabbit hole because
we would we would be here for like 45
minutes yeah um
maybe for another show yeah the other
thing i'd say is like not only do people
need to
report their hypotheses but like there
really really needs to be a more robust
system
and a more robust set of expectations
that like
not only will you report your hypotheses
in the study but that like
you will either pre-register hypotheses
beforehand or publish registered reports
where like
you have to state your hypotheses
beforehand um
oh man i don't have the paper pulled up
in front of me but
i feel like i can describe it reasonably
well so i think we've we've talked about
registered reports on the podcast before
but just like a very very brief primer
on them again for people who missed that
episode
in the traditional publishing model
basically you get a study approved you
collect the data you analyze it you
write it up
then you submit it for publication and
it either gets accepted or rejected
with registered reports you develop
an idea for a study and generally first
step would still be getting it approved
by ethics at your school
and then once that's done you just
basically submit the methods and the
data analysis plan to a journal
and the journal either accepts it and
says like hey
uh you know based on what you say you're
going to do and how you're going to
analyze your data
we think that whatever the results are
it will be valuable to our readers
or they reject it they say like your
methods are [ __ ] the way you want to
analyze this data is stupid we don't
want this
um and so with a registered report
once you get it accepted before you do
it
like before you actually carry out the
study and then once you carry out the
study
you analyze the data the way you said
you were going to and then you publish
it
and after after the paper's been
accepted on the front end where you just
submitted your methods and data analysis
plan
whatever your results are the journal
will publish it as long as you actually
did the study the way you said you were
going to and analyze the data
the way you said you were going to so
anyway with with that background
um the thing with registered reports is
like it removes the incentive
to do dodgy stuff with data either just
to sit on it if you don't get the
results you wanted
or to you know hark
or p hack or you know change your
hypotheses after the fact
uh in order to get a significant result
that might be more publishable
so like it basically removes those
incentives because the paper has already
been accepted just on the strength of
the methods
and so in psychology they are starting
to publish
more registered reports and so there's
there's been at least a couple studies
that compare
the rates of statistically significant
positive results in the direction of the
author's hypotheses
in traditional papers versus registered
reports
and in traditional papers it's like 80
85
in registered reports it's like 50 60
which which checks out like you know if
people know their field like they're
gonna
generate hypotheses that pan out more
often than not
but there's like a way way lower success
rate in registered reports than
traditional articles so like
do with that information what you will
yeah yeah and so
for more information on this kind of
stuff our most recent fireside chat
we talked all about the particulars of
like open science and registered reports
and all that stuff so listeners can go
isn't it
two fireside chats ago it was one of the
fireside chats
one of one of the fairly recent ones
yeah it's out there
uh another paper uh along these same
lines it was called
call to increase statistical
collaboration
in sports science sport and exercise
medicine
and sports physiotherapy so it's
basically a paper saying hey everybody
uh let's do some good stats uh it was uh
you know it's
just a a positive thing you know hey
let's let's go
let's start doing better with this stuff
which is good you know it was uh
but but what they were basically calling
for i think their biggest
uh request uh in this paper is basically
listen you're an exercise scientist and
let let's be clear exercise scientists
like
you have to be an expert in the theory
of the topic you study you have to be an
expert in the methods which are not easy
to do
i mean there's a lot of methods that are
highly technical
uh you have to like build apparatuses to
like
actually make it work right so if you go
to like a neuromuscular focused
laboratory
they've got all sorts of contraptions
where they had to bring in an engineer
and a carpenter and they've got to be
like
you know they need someone who's like an
electrical engineer to do all the
you know all the stuff they're trying to
do so it's
it's advanced theory it's advanced very
technical methods
and then on top of that in your free
time you're supposed to learn how to be
a statistician
at a high level so like we're asking a
lot of of exercise scientists
without collaboration and so this paper
saying like
what if you just did collaborate you
know so like
reach out to people in these fields that
are more quantitative
in focus team up with a biostatistician
a statistician a data scientist
an epidemiologist an epidemiologist a
mathematician
all these different fields that do some
of this very quantitative work and might
be able to
make your statistical analysis even
better
without you needing to somehow find
enough free time to basically get a phd
in biostats
right because that ain't gonna happen
with all the stuff you're currently
doing
um and i will say this so in my short
publishing career i have had
the privilege of collaborating with a
biostatistician an
epidemiologist and a mathematician
across different projects and those have
been awesome projects
i'm telling you if you're a sports
scientist listening to this or if you're
a student who wants to get into research
if you can find ways to collaborate with
those people uh
it's a really fantastic idea um
the coolest projects i've done uh
analyses where i didn't have to
you know completely lead the way and was
able to learn from
from the more skilled people doing it
really really good stuff
uh okay so greg i don't think we're
gonna have time for a q a segment
i think we might want to do our coach's
corner and uh and call it a day how do
you feel about that
yeah that works cool so uh q a
we'll do them all next episode we're
going to be putting them up every two
weeks folks
we are back uh so let me scroll ahead
here
to the coach's corner yeah so this is
a question that uh quite a few people
have messaged me about so
um on my personal instagram page
at trexler fitness some of the hottest
content on instagram
and a lot of people are saying maybe too
hot for instagram
but but for now i'm posting um so on my
personal page
i i started doing something called
recommended reads where i basically say
like hey here's a cool
exercise science article or paper or
whatever
go check that out and so what i shared
was um there was a review paper by
mike israel and colleagues called
mesocycle progression in hypertrophy
volume versus intensity and
so basically the whole idea of their
paper was that
uh their assessment of the literature
would suggest that kind of the ideal way
to make
progression occur throughout the course
of a mesocycle from week to week
is by adding additional sets into the
program
now brian miner and colleagues including
the good doctor
eric helms they published a letter to
the editor
a kind of a response to this paper and
they argued
against a number of points in the paper
and suggested a slightly different way
of progressing things throughout the
course
of a mesocycle and so i shared this
this back and forth and a lot of people
asked you know
eric what what's your approach to
progressing things along
over the course of a mesocycle and also
and probably more importantly what's
greg's approach
because greg is the training guy so greg
over the course of a mesocycle week to
week we're going to be adjusting
some training variables um you know to
kind of nudge things along
i assume so i mean what do you have any
strong feelings one way or the other
because
this turned into uh they kind of did
like a round table on the revive
stronger podcast with
with steve hall and uh you know there's
a lot of back and forth do you have any
what camp are you in if any
uh i i'm probably closer to the helms
camp
honestly uh so
let me start by
arguing against that and why i think
there might be
some uh some value in in progressing
sets on like shorter time scales
one is that um
so the the first reason that i think
there might be value in
in progressing sets over the course of a
meso cycle
is there's not say like rcts
showing that that's the best way to
approach it but there are a few studies
where uh like basically what they do is
they take
people uh ask them what their training
has looked like for
like the two three four weeks leading up
to the study get a baseline of how many
sets that they were previously doing
and then increase their set volume by
like 20 percent
uh and like there will be different like
research questions layered on top of
that but like that's the way they go
about dictating volume in those studies
um and one of the things i've noticed
about those studies is they tend to have
relatively low non-response rates
compared to the broader literature so
especially if you're doing research on
trained individuals
it's not incredibly uncommon for
say between like a quarter and a fifth
of your subjects to
not gain muscle over the course of the
study which makes sense um
i don't like the term non-responder
because they're probably not
non-responders in a general sense but
like hey
you know the the training intervention
you
that you're using in the study may
either be excessive for some folks or
not enough for some folks and so
you wind up with uh with non-trivial
rates of
non-response where people fail to get
bigger in in the studies i've seen where
the way they dictate volume is a 20
increase from an individual's baseline
uh they tend to have pretty low rates of
non-response which
suggests that volume increases in terms
of
the number of sets people are doing is a
pretty reliable way
not necessarily to maximize hypertrophy
strictly but to
just ensure that some hypertrophy will
occur
like over the next eight weeks or 12
weeks or something like that
and the thing i'll note about that is
that's it
i don't know a ton about how mike
programs training mike issertel but i
think that's different
from the way he does it because that's
essentially like we're going to bump
your volume up 20
and you're going to stay at this 20
elevated level for the next two or three
months versus like
you know we're gonna bump you up 20
percent in another four weeks we're
going to bump you up another 10
and another four weeks we're going to
bump you up another 10 but but anyway
um to some degree it seems like volume
increases
help with like the reliability of
like muscle hypertrophy occurring yeah
in in this uh in the paper itself they
have like a diagram where they add
two sets every week oh yeah that's
not what they're doing in those studies
that i'm describing
yeah so over six weeks in this figure it
goes from 10
up to 20 sets and then week seven drops
down to five
yeah yeah so that's not what they're
doing in the studies i'm talking about
that's like a 20 increase in just
staying at 20
right um the other thing i would say is
that
of of of the targets that you can kind
of aim at
for like prescribing training variables
and keeping people engaged i think that
adding sets
is a pretty decent tool in the arsenal
because
uh and i think that's especially true
for exercises you can't
load quite as heavily so you know let's
say
you have someone um who's doing dumbbell
press
and their current working weight is 40
pounds per hand
uh and the next jump they're going to
take is to 45 which is
in excess of a 10 jump and load
so you know that's they need to get
quite a bit stronger before they can
still do
a fair number of reps with that load
increase
um and so but but also like
you know if you change from say
having them aim for sets of eight to
sets of ten
uh you know you can probably do sets of
eight at like eighty percent of one rm
and you can probably do sets of ten at
like seventy five percent
of one rm and so you know to go from say
prescribing three sets of eight to three
sets of ten
uh they might have to get five percent
stronger so that's still like a
relatively big
jump whereas it seems like
uh especially when sets aren't taken to
failure folks seem to get
maybe like three ish percent weaker
on average set to set and so you know if
if someone
can knock out say three sets of eight
uh and you want to eventually progress
them towards being able to do
three sets of ten uh and maybe three
sets of twelve before you bump them up
to the 45 pound dumbbells
what you could do and what i tend to do
is get
to the point that they can do three sets
of eight and then before we try to jump
to sets of ten
we go to four sets of eight because
they'll be able to complete the fourth
set of eight before they'll be able to
complete the third set of 10.
um so it's not so much about
increasing volume per se it's more about
folks who like quantitative goals in
terms of like here's the weight i'm
working with
and i want a sudden rep goal to work
towards and then just what's reasonable
so what i tend to do is like three sets
of eight four sets of eight five sets of
eight
then jump to sets of ten three sets of
ten four sets of ten five sets of ten
then jump to sets of twelve three sets
of twelve four sets of 12 5 sets of 12
and then increase load uh and generally
again for exercises where
you're dealing with large relative load
increases so you know if someone has to
jump from like 30 to 35 pound dumbbells
for a particular exercise
um so and again that's not so much about
trying to increase volume to maximize
hypertrophy it's more just about
giving people reasonable
quantitative goals to shoot for to keep
them and excited and engaged
and allowing them to make like
quantitative progress that keeps them
invested
um so yeah those are some reasons why
i might would argue in favor of set
increases across like
somewhat shorter time scales but i think
that
i think that in general um
like so if you think about training
conceptually and you assume that like
for an individual
there's a given level of volume that is
the best for them
like we don't know what that is that's a
needle in the haystack that you're
looking for but like theoretically
there's probably going to be some level
of volume
that's ideal for that individual and
then
my opinion this could be right this
could be wrong
this is how i feel is that there's kind
of a plateau
where along that plateau you're
basically doing more work but not
getting
much extra in return so i don't think
that you hit a pinnacle
on kind of the volume hypertrophy
relationship
and then immediately start dropping off
so you know let's say that
for a given lift uh like four sets per
exercise is ideal for you
i don't think five sets is going to be
worse than four i think it's gonna be
pretty similar
and maybe up to like eight sets will get
you similar growth and then it's gonna
start dropping off from there
um so i think that like you
you can wind up in a situation where
you're doing more and more work and not
really getting much extra in return for
it
um and one thing i'll note is that like
that's not just my feeling like i think
the the general volume dose response
research kind of supports that where
really really low volumes tend to not
cause much hypertrophy
and then in in studies that have like
three levels of volume
generally like moderate and high have
relatively similar
similar results uh as far as hypertrophy
goes so
i i think that like
past a certain point you're just kind of
progressing through that dead zone where
you're doing more work and not really
getting
much extra in return for it um
and then like you know there's there's
also the question of
uh of risk and um
just like risk in roi like if you can
if you can theoretically do like a third
less volume than you're currently doing
and still get the same basic results
like
one it's just inefficient to do more and
then
two like injuries inevitably happen like
that's
just something that occurs with training
um
and if you
so we don't know like 100 all of the
risk factors
for injuries and resistance training but
just like
exposure seems to be a big one that like
people who do more total training
whether that's putting in more hours per
week
putting in more sets per workout like
however you want to quantify it people
who have a greater number of exposures
seem to get injured more often kind of
per unit of calendar time so like
if it's basically like what's my risk of
getting injured in the next year
the more you train the greater your risk
is um
kind of all else being equal um
and so i mean like i think to some
degree you're just increasing
your your exposure and risk and like i
said
previously probably not getting too much
in return for it
so i think that your your better bet is
just to try to find
a level of volume that that works that
allows you to accomplish what you want
to accomplish
it is helping you get stronger it is
help it is helping you get bigger
um and just stick with that until it
isn't working anymore and then
you know and then you may need to
increase volume from there or you may
need to decrease volume from there um
one of the things i've noticed talking
to
like really really strong lifters and
this is true for myself as well like
the level of training volume that works
best for me now
currently is quite a bit lower than it
was when i was
quite a bit weaker um and i think that's
just because like
the amount of of stimulus i'm capable of
exposing myself to and the amount of
stress i'm capable of putting on my body
on a per set basis
is just a lot higher than it used to be
when i wasn't as strong as i am now
um and that's not the case for every
really strong person i know but it
seems to be the case for like a
non-negligible number of them
uh and so i i one would push back
against just
the progression of volume over time for
everyone in all situations period
uh and two like those
those general changes in optimal volume
levels
in my experience seem to take place on
this
time scale of years or maybe months
certainly not weeks yeah i think another
thing
from a practical perspective is i know
that a lot of my clients
are they're very busy and they
they like training so they don't like
short workouts but they also like i said
they're busy so they don't like workouts
that drag on and on and on
and so as set number if there's really
large fluctuations
in set number from week to week across
the course of a meso cycle
i think i know that many of my clients
would
frankly be annoyed by the variation in
the duration of workouts
as you kind of climbed up from very few
sets to a large number of sets per
workout
so like just having the the duration of
the workout be a little bit more fixed
and a little bit more reliable
and predictable from from workout to
workout and week to week i think a lot
of people
practically enjoy that as a feature of a
program
and you know when you mentioned there's
a lot of exercises
you know when you get into accessory
work where each incremental jump is big
you know and so you're like well we
can't just add another increment and
wait because we're not ready for that
yet
uh and man that was never more true than
uh when every gym in the world shut down
and uh all of a sudden a lot of my
clients said like
all right eric you know good news i have
a home gym bad news
i've got three dumbbells you know what i
mean it's like it was like okay
i've got two sets i've got some 30s and
some 70s exactly
yeah so it's like okay are we ready to
jump from 30 to 70
probably not yet and so it kind of made
me get creative with
you know how are we going to continue
bumping this along without making a jump
in the weight we're using and in the
response paper
uh brian miner and colleagues kind of
laid out a double progression method
where it's like okay well
let's use that fixed load let's keep
bumping reps up
with a particular reps and reserve
target and once we're hitting a large
number of reps
with that given proximity to failure now
we know okay
let's bump up the load and drop down to
the lower end
of our acceptable repetition range so so
using things like that
has been really helpful rather than just
saying well let's add another
set on i would say well let's let's get
some more reps this week
but maintain our proximity to failure
and adjust things that way
and eventually we can kind of bump
things up
you know even though we have a limited
number of options in terms of loading so
uh so yeah i mean you know i i of course
anyone that puts together a program
at some point is going to fluctuate the
number of sets that exists in the
program
but i'm definitely more inclined to do
that
block to block or mesocycle to mesocycle
rather than within mesocycle you know if
we're getting to the point where i'm
like okay we need to
make a relatively large incremental jump
up in our volume i'll probably add that
at the beginning
of the next mesocycle and kind of ease
into that higher volume
as we go um cool i i think people will
be satisfied with that response greg
i think you uh made your thoughts known
that's useful
practical stuff cool um can we do one q
a
i really want to do the wilk score one
yeah okay
um let's see here uh is this the yeah
it's kenny yeah kenny asked this so the
other day i was looking at the outline
and i the only thing i saw
the only thing i saw was a specific line
that said
let's assume paul rudd is an average
power lifter
and i was like what are you responding
to so
kenny asks uh can you
calculate or estimate based on evidence
in the documentary film
ant-man what ant-man's wilkes score
would be and is ant-man's wilkes score
achievable as a natural lifter yeah so
that is
a great question which is why
everybody's been thinking it so
somebody had to ask no for sure i and
and i appreciate
uh kenny's intellectual curiosity
and and bravery for being willing to ask
this question
so yeah i love this question which is
why i wanted to shoehorn it into this
episode
um and there's there's levels to this so
the
so the first thing to keep in mind is
that uh
ant-man i think canonically like how his
power is supposed to work
is that he's able to shrink or grow but
like basically his strength
doesn't change as he shrinks or grows so
like he can be the size of an ant
and still be as strong as a normal sized
man
conversely when he grows really really
big he's like
he seems weak and moves very sluggishly
because
you know he now has way more mass
because he's much larger but he's not
any stronger than he was when he was
normal size like i
i'm pretty sure that's how ant-man's
power set works
um and so the the
room temperature iq way of approaching
this question
is being like okay well wilks is
essentially
like a very very complex like fifth
order polynomial strength to body weight
ratio
uh lighter people have higher wilk
scores if their total
is the same therefore uh ant-man
could shrink and shrink and shrink his
mass would get smaller and smaller
tending towards zero and therefore
his will score could be infinite if he
was still capable of
like lifting a bar any distance
whatsoever
um like i said that is the room
temperature iq way of approaching this
question because
uh it completely misunderstands how the
wilkes score works
so uh wilkes score is kind of like a
fancy strength to body weight ratio
but the difference between wilkes score
and strength of body weight ratios
is that the the y-intercept
of the wilkes formula is not at zero so
uh at zero body weight uh or like
as you approach zero body mass it
doesn't actually like
keep getting lower and lower and lower
so
the normal iq way of approaching this
would be to say like okay well let's get
the fifth order polynomial that defines
a wilkes score
let's plot it and then let's see if
there are any vertical asymptotes
which there are there are two vertical
asymptotes at kind of
not completely ridiculous body weights i
guess
so one is a vertical asymptote at a body
weight
slightly below 13 and a half kilos and
the other is a vertical
asymptote slightly above 283 kilos
and so you could look at that and say
like hey
there is a perfect body mass
that he could shrink himself down to and
then no matter what he lifted
at that body mass his his will score
would be virtually infinite
um so yeah like that
seems like it makes sense but like i
said that's the normal iq
here's the galaxy brain approach which
actually knows how wilks functions
so if you go to like if you if you just
go to the wikipedia page for wilk score
it'll give you the coefficients to plot
the fifth order polynomial that like
defines the wilks coefficients
but that's not actually how wilk scored
is calculated
the actual real legit wilkes score is
literally just a table of coefficients
and that is what wilkes score is and so
it goes from 40 to 205 kilos for male
lifters
and so if you're a male lifter and
you're less than 40 kilos
you don't plug it into the the formula
the fifth order polynomial to get it
you just assume that whoever it is
weighs exactly 40 kilos anyone under 40
kilos
is 40 kilos for all intents and purposes
for wilks
and anyone above 205 kilos is exactly
205 kilos for the purposes of wilkes
uh so that's how it actually functions
the the formula doesn't [ __ ] matter
it's literally just the table of
coefficients and that is
wilkes um and so
the best that paul rudd could actually
do or ant-man
uh is he could shrink down such that his
body mass is 40 kilos
and then just lift what he lifts uh and
that is the best his will score could
possibly
be and so uh the line that eric was
referring to in the outline is
let's assume paul rudd is a more or less
average
male power lifter and so somewhere
around the median performance
for male power lifters is a squat around
200 kilos bench around 150
deadlifts around 250. so
a total of about 600 kilos if you
totaled 600 kilos at a body mass of 40
kilos
uh your wilk score would be about 801
uh and and so that's like the original
wilks i know there was a new wilkes
formula that came out this year
no one [ __ ] uses it uh the ipf has
moved on i think
like the one federation in australia
that wilks himself is still associated
with uses the new wilkes formula
who gives a [ __ ] the wilkes that
everyone knows
and i would say loves but i think
everyone hated it is like
the older version of the formula so
that's what we're going with
uh so with that version you hate it but
it's familiar correct yeah yeah
uh so with that version of the formula
his wilks would be about 801.
the best wilks ever by anyone competing
raw
uh was mariana gasparian uh so her
wilkes was 720
and the best wilkes score ever in a drug
tested meet
was uh andre stenazik at 598
so to answer kenny's question
what would the wealth score be and is it
achievable natty
probably around 801 assuming he's more
or less average and i don't think
that that's achievable natty uh
the thing is like i'm generally pretty
optimistic about the progression of the
sport of powerlifting like it's
the best lifters have gotten a lot
better over the last decade
i think that there's still probably room
to improve
but for for the best tested wilks to go
from like right at 600 to right at 800
that would entail the assumption that
lifters can get
about a third better than they currently
are
and i i really just don't see that
happening
it may happen maybe i'm a pessimist uh
i have been on the optimistic side of
things as far as the progression of the
sport has gone
up to this point i just don't see
i just don't see the top lifters getting
a full
third better than they currently are so
uh
no i do not think uh ant-man's woke
score
would be achievable natty so now
everybody can stop
asking right it's every week i'm getting
this question yeah stop blowing my inbox
up about that
uh however if you want me to stay on as
a permanent
co-host of this show you should blow up
eric's inbox
asking him to keep me on if
a hundred people message him before the
next episode comes
i will stay on and be promoted to
permanent co-host we talked about this
before we started recording
if a hundred people don't message him uh
i will be kicked off the podcast
permanently
um and do what everyone has been
expecting me to do
this whole time which is uh
raise a gorilla army and lay siege to
the netherlands so
those are your options if you're
listening to this a quick correction
it's not
messages before the next episode
as long it's the the messages have to
get in before october 7th
that's the day so
so before this episode comes out
listen that's five days make it happen
um
all right so to play us out we are at
the end of the episode here
um it's october we're recording this on
october 2nd
october means big ten football is back
in about three weeks here and if if
football's back it means barbecue
is on so to play us out we've got some
barbecue tips i'm gonna go first because
you don't want to miss
what i've got to say about this people
ask me for cooking tips all the time
so uh first of all i'm just gonna make a
controversial statement that is actually
a fact
eastern carolina barbecue sauce is the
best version of barbecue sauce
is that vinegar-based or mustard-based
heavy vinegar
some black pepper in there because both
of those are eastern north carolina
barbecue sauces
i like the mustard one too i've been
getting a lot of barbecue sauce at the
grocery store for my shredded chicken
a big surprise it's going on shredded
chicken everybody
uh but yeah the the super vinegar based
with some black pepper
is amazing and then the these equally
vinegar based with some mustard in it
is also a beautiful thing um people
argue about other kinds of barbecue
styles that are
they're very good but the eastern
carolina barbecue
in terms of sauces you just can't beat
it now here's what i've been doing
for people who are keeping an eye on
their macros a little bit my coleslaw
recipe
out of this world so you go get the
actual like vegetable mix
for coleslaw which is just a bunch of
chopped up cabbage a little bit of
carrot in there
um but it's just like getting a bag of
salad greens you know
at the grocery store so i get the uh
the vegetables all chopped up ready to
go uh put them in a bowl here's what you
put in
you put in uh greek yogurt
and mix that in there and you put in
just
a little bit of dijon mustard and a
little bit of splenda
you got a little bit of tangy a little
bit of sweet you mix it all up
it's really good coleslaw and that's all
i got
get some shredded chicken in there throw
some sauce on it you're good to go
no salt i know because i
i eat it all in a big combination so
the um the barbecue sauce is a little
bit salty
i got you yeah it's good stuff man uh
sure i mean i like honestly as far as
like macro friendly stuff goes that
sounds fine
uh if you ever wanted to thin it out a
little bit like throwing a splash of uh
apple cider vinegar in there would
probably be pretty good yeah i might try
that
cool uh okay so so my barbecue tip
is for anyone who wants to make like a
pretty adequate rack of ribs indoors
so it's not that hard to smoke ribs as
long as you can
uh like control the temperature of your
smoker reasonably well
like decent smoked ribs are trivially
easy
but i know a lot of people either don't
have a smoker or like you live in
an apartment and so like that's just
logistically not feasible
and so if you want something that isn't
going to replace
good smoked ribs but at least comes
reasonably close
that you can do indoors in your kitchen
here is a good option so
first thing i'd strongly strongly
recommend
using a sous-vide circulator if you
can afford one if you can't you can do
it without it but sous-vide makes it
easier
and the resulting ribs will be juicier
but i'll give you tips for whether or
not you have the sous-vide circulator
so to start with i'm a big
big fan of brining pretty much any meat
uh and ribs are no exception so i think
uh
good ribs start with a good brine if you
have the time to do so
so just make a two percent salt solution
brine your ribs overnight in that salt
solution
and put it in a relatively shallow
container so that it doesn't need as
much brine
to cover the ribs and then here's the
important part
so they make um they make like
cheap smoking contraptions that you can
either use like on your countertop or in
your oven
uh and all of those just seem to me to
be like
more trouble than they're actually worth
a very simple solution to getting
something that tastes smoky that you
don't actually have to smoke is just
using liquid smoke
which isn't as good as just like regular
ass smoke and i know people throw shade
on liquid smoke but like
honestly it's fine like if you if you
want to get that smoky flavor
and especially if we're talking about
ribs which are probably going to be
applying a dry rub too
and maybe some sauce it's not as
noticeable that it's liquid smoke so
you know if you just want like smoky
bacon and it's the difference between
like
actually smoking it and the only other
flavor going on is just salt
it's going to be [ __ ] obvious that
you use liquid smoke but for ribs like
you can honestly get away with it so add
some liquid smoke to your brine that
you're going to be soaking the ribs in
and add a little bit more than you think
you need so mix them in
sniff it when it smells a little smokier
than you think it needs to smell it's
probably pretty good
and the reason you want to get it a
little too smoky is it's not going to
get like super super deep into the ribs
so anyway you get your smoky brine
two percent salt solution soak the ribs
overnight
and then uh the next day if you're
using sous vide what you would then do
is take the ribs out of the brine pat
them dry
apply a dry rub i personally prefer to
use
just plain yellow mustard as a binder
you can use whatever you want
and for your dry rub i'd either
recommend no salt in it since you've
already brined the ribs or just
very very light salt because if you are
brining your ribs beforehand they could
wind up too salty
if you use a salty dry rub you go ahead
and apply your dry rub
put it in a sous-vide bag and sous-vide
at
165 degrees fahrenheit for about 10 to
12 hours
that'll get you some some nice soft ribs
that aren't just like
completely falling apart and then once
that's done
you've removed from the bag you apply
some sauce or glaze
if you so choose or you know you can
just leave them with only the dry rub
pop them in a really hot oven so at
least 450 degrees fahrenheit
or if you're going to be watching them
pretty close
just you can go ahead and pop them under
a broiler and all that's going to do is
like
really get everything nice and bubbly if
you apply to sauce or glaze that's gonna
help it set
um if you do use a broiler be really
really careful of burning
especially if there was sugar in your
dry rub or sauce because
if the sugar burns and like actually
turns black it's going to be super
bitter and tastes like [ __ ]
um but yeah so that that's if you're
sous eating
if you don't have a sous vide system
that's totally fine
um once you've uh
like once you brine the ribs overnight
same process pat it dry
apply your dry rub and then uh
bake at a low temperature almost as if
you were smoking so like
maybe 250 degrees uh and just temp it
every so often so
ribs like you don't want medium ribs
that's going to be a problem there's
going to be a lot of unrendered fat
there's going to be a lot of connective
tissue that hasn't broken down yet
so you want to get your ribs up to about
165 170 give or take
but yeah just keep it in a low oven
until you reach that internal
temperature and then
exact same process as before crank the
temperature up
apply your sauce and or glaze if that's
what you're using
get everything nice and bubbly and
sizzly
and they'll be pretty decent ribs again
not as good
as legit smoked ribs but not a terrible
simulacrum to be able to make indoors in
a kitchen all right and
always when you make those ribs put a
little bit of the old trexler coleslaw
on the side of the plate it's going to
go well
perfectly together um okay so that does
it for
our first episode back from summer break
before we leave i want to remind you to
join in on the stronger by science
conversation by going to the facebook
group
or the subreddit and again the facebook
group is called the stronger by science
community so along those lines be sure
to be a good
member of those communities be kind to
each other be helpful to each other
greg and i are going to have a presence
there the other stronger by science
coaches are also going to have a
presence there so
it's a great place to discuss all things
stronger by science and really just
all things training and nutrition in
general
you know greg and i get a lot of direct
messages with questions about training
and nutrition and of course we're happy
to receive those happy to answer them
but they're generally really good
questions and other people
benefit from seeing those interactions
and joining in
on those conversations themselves so be
sure to check out those
online communities and we will see you
there
as always thank you for listening to the
stronger by science podcast and we will
be back with our next episode
in two weeks thank you for listening to
the stronger by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs
for all skill levels and all schedules
we hate spam just as much as you do
so we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
you can sign up for the free newsletter
at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter or just go to the stronger by
science homepage and click the free
programs button at the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation
be sure to check out our facebook group
and our subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits
be sure to check with a qualified health
care professional
once again thank you for listening and
we will be back soon with another
episode of the stronger by science
[Music]
podcast
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you